la droite c'est des députés qui agissent
qui contrôle le gouvernement qui propose
et qui sont responsables d'un parti le
gouvernement et donc voila moi j'entends
avoir à des députés qui comme ils l'ont
fait ont été des députés responsables et
contraindre emmanuel macron à ramener
dans notre pays la sécurité la bonne
gestion la maîtrise de l'immigration
l'élection de présidentielle un côté et
il ya tous nos députés d'un autre qui
sont très ancrés enraciné sur le dans
notre territoire et je peux vous dire
que ça c'est la force des républicains
sont pas sont pas des des élus virtuels
sont pas des élus et présidents de
région des présences de départements de
la cjrs les l'air était bien sûr et des
parlementaires et nous détenons si senna
enfin la présidence du sénat a exercé
par gérard larcher c'est ma famille
politique nous avons aussi des
parlementaires européens donc nous
sommes la première force d'opposition